[Music]
foreign
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the political journalists for the
financial times and the sun Jasmine
Cameron chaleshi and Noah Hoffman
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now or the eye
reports Liz Trouse will encourage her
party to put on a United front as many
polls show labor far ahead
it's the same story for the express
their headline Rebels urged to stop
plots and show loyalty
but the guardian understands there's a
growing rebellion in the Tory ranks over
the policy not to have state benefits
rise in line with inflation
the star here's people are heading to
bakeries in an attempt to stay warm amid
the cost of living crisis
the Metro describes the retaliatory
attacks after the destruction of the
bridge-linking Crimea and the Russian
Mainland as a display of the wrath of
Putin
same story in the telegraph which
reports that Mr Putin has described the
attack as an act of terrorism by Ukraine
the male turns to so-called woke culture
which it claims is now pervading
universities and forcing them to change
the way they teach several subjects
the U.S treasury secretary has described
the decision of the OPEC nations to cut
production as unwise according to the
financial times
and the son says the next series of the
crown is likely to prove controversial
as it shows Prince Philip pursuing an
affair
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by Jasmine
Cameron chileshi and Noah Hoffman
welcome to you both let's start with the
eye and um their story essentially
saying that the the prime minister's
scrambling to save her her Premiership
at this early stage Jasmine
yeah so let's trust us on a bit of the
charm events of this week so we know
she's got pmqs where she'll face up
against labor leader care starmer we
know that she's also due to face back
benches in the 1922 committee she'll
have a cabinet meeting later this week
so it's been a very Rocky start for this
trust obviously she was elected pm and
then she had the death of the queen and
the Fallout from her mini budget and we
saw from last week's um Tory Party
Conference that actually the party isn't
very unified at the moment we had
cabinet ministers over me disagreeing
with each other we had senior back
Ventures such as Michael Gove openly
criticizing the government and we also
held the U-turn so she's now in a
position where she really has to win
over her MPS and convince them of her
agenda and it's important to note that
trust has this huge parliamentary
majority but it's not because of her
personal popularity with either the
public or MPS it's a legacy from Boris
Johnson who managed to gain this
majority in the 2019 general election by
winning over voters in the so-called red
wall and blue ball seats and so she's
got this huge majority but it really
seems like she's losing political
capital and political Goodwill among her
back benches and she's got a few pieces
of tricky legislation whether that's on
benefits or fracking or trying to get
some of her economic policies pushed
through and she's really gonna need to
have MPS on side in order to actually
get that through the House of Commons
and no it does really seem as though
she's bending to pressure the article
suggesting that she's going to be
delaying reforms to persuade plotting
back benches the eye says one veteran MP
has said to them we will get rid of her
I can't see how she sacked and
ostracized anyone who didn't support her
and expects to carry on most of us don't
think trust is very good
yeah she really is in quite a
predicament at the moment Jasmine was
absolutely right however I don't see a
way forward for her and a way for her to
reunite the party without fundamentally
changing the policy platform and the
ideological standing on which she stood
for the Tory leadership which is quite a
sort of hard right libertarian world
view that differs quite differently
um from that of Boris Johnson who was
the Democrat democratically uh elected
prime minister and we've seen MPS point
that out such as the former cabinet
heavyweights Nadine dory's Grant Sharps
Michael Gove so if she does want to
unite her party and I'm sure she does it
will probably involve a massive Retreat
from those values that she holds very
closely to her going back years that's
going to make her seem weak though isn't
it Jasmine
I think so but also there is an element
of being realistic it's quite strong
striking you noted the quote on the
front of the eye that actually senior
MPS are openly speculating about trust's
future where how long she's going to
last who will replace her and she's only
been in power for what maybe just over a
month it really does show that she's in
quite a politically weak position and
bear in mind that you know this is a
party that was filled with infighting at
the end of Johnson's Premiership and the
argument put forward by Tory MPS is that
actually you know there were better
leaders waiting in the wings trust would
be able to unify the party be able to
put the party and the country back on
track and the past month has been pretty
chaotic and I think you know that her
team around her will have to be
incredibly realistic they'll have to
look at the polls a lot of MPS
especially those who are you know
potentially facing
um lib Dems those MPS in the red wall um
part of the UK were facing labor you
know they'll be worried about their
seats they'll be worried about the
upcoming general election and so I think
there is an element of actually having
to be a bit realistic and recognize that
there has been a strong reaction to some
of her policies and she's going to have
to adapt a new turn on some of those if
need be and the suggestion is that that
people are plotting against her that
there are Rebels plotting against her
the express saying that they're being
told to stop that and to show loyalty
but can you order loyalty Noah
well I suppose that's the job of the
chief Whip and her the Wendy Morton's
critics say she's doing quite a poor job
of that there's been some discussion of
her being replaced in the role given how
uh Tory Party Conference played out
which was quite amazing really
um I'm just thinking back to the
Conservative Party Conference at
Manchester and thinking about how that
went when it was sort of peak Boris
everyone was United behind him he was
sort of the king of the party
um versus what we saw in Birmingham
where we had cabinet ministers going
rogue uh and we had back benches coming
out the Woodworks to you know decry the
policies that Liz truss was putting
forward she needs a really really strong
whip in place to you know get the party
into shape get the party behind her and
we've seen some some of that come out uh
this weekend in the papers we've had
cabinet ministers go to all the main
sort of national newspapers and their
line is get behind Liz trust or get
ready for a kissed on the government now
is is that going to be enough I'm not
sure I've spoken to some MPS who have
told me actually they're solely focused
on retaining their seats right now
rather than you know sort of keeping the
conservative party up in the polls
they're just focused on their
constituency and sort of surviving the
next election rather than the wider goal
of the Tory party winning so it's just a
huge mountain to climb and whether she
can do that
um remains to be seen uh Jasmine and
then the point that I was making is if
you have to order loyalty it rather
suggests that that you you do not have
the Loyalty of the the people that
you're working with
yeah I think that's true and it's
important to note that trust has
effectively filled her cabinet with
Loyalists and those who are aligned with
her on her economic vision and political
vision for the country but she's got
back benches filled with you know
individuals such as Nadine Doris who
always um supported people like Boris
Johnson you've got you've got former
cabinet heavyweights such as Michael
Gove where she's sunac so you've got
quite she's got quite a skeptical you
know House of Commons to deal with and I
think it's important to touch on Noah's
point that actually MPS are hearing from
their constituents they're getting
emails they're getting letters of
constituents worried about the rising
costs of servicing their mortgages their
Rising costs of energy bills and they're
really worried about some of the you
know economic impacts of trusses
policies and actually at the end of the
day if the public has lost confidence in
trust and there's lost confidence in the
government it doesn't really matter what
the whipping operation is like because
people will you know people will turn
out in the polls against the the Tories
it there is an element of you know MPS
these are trying to be a bit more
cynical and they are thinking about
protecting their own seats but it does
come down to the fact that if the public
doesn't like your policies that will
eventually impact a party at the polls
regardless of whatever you tell MPS to
say to the public and the cost of living
crisis are looming larger over many of
her problems the the star taking a
little bit of an irreverent look at that
their headline let them heat cake and
this story about people going to
bakeries to actually keep warm Noah
yeah it's absolutely tragic
um and it's not their fault you know uh
working people hard-working Brits aren't
responsible for Putin's war in Ukraine
for the covered pandemic uh for perhaps
economic mismanagement
um and all the sort of global factors as
well that have left us where we are and
it's a job of government to come in to
step in and protect us where we can't
protect ourselves from these sort of
crises I think if you have people as the
star reports having to go to bakeries to
get warm that's going to stick in their
mind at a general election they're going
to think will labor will a labor
government mean that I have to go to my
local library to my local sort of town
hall to stay warm or um will I be okay
in my home now In fairness to the
government they have introduced an
energy price guarantee which is really
important and it is such a great step
forward
um it will see prices capped at 2 500
pounds now that is not an ABS absolute
caps um it could be some people could go
a bit over or a bit under but they have
stepped in to do something now when you
see people heading to bakeries to stay
warm and you see policies such as
Bankers bonuses being lifted the Optics
of the two when you put them together is
kind of What's led us to this mess in
the conservative party in the first
place What's led us to these sort of
rebellions and and this uh discomfort
among the back benches and stories like
this are very striking for those reasons
so
um and I suspect we'll see more of them
to come yes uh Bankers bonuses uh
juxtaposed with the people going to
bakeries to to keep warmer makes the the
point doesn't it thank you both for the
moment we're going to take a break
coming up as the next series of the
crown that's set to depict Prince Philip
pursuing an affair we'll discuss that
next
thank you
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview still with me Jasmine Cameron
chaleshi and Noah Hoffman ah there you
are I thought you deserted me for a
moment
um let's start with you Jasmine this
section having a look at the Metro their
headline Wrath of Putin and this is this
attack on a domestic apartments in
zapparesia by the Russians following on
from the the uh well blowing up of the
Crimea Bridge
yes it's quite a harrowing Metro front
page and it really speaks to a President
Putin who's actually been emboldened by
the attack I mean this is a bridge that
was strategically important for Russia
and it marks you know a bit of
humiliation for someone like Putin who
expected
um it to be pretty easy to to defeat the
Ukrainian forces and I think the big
question for Western officials looking
on is actually what does President Putin
do from here I mean he's increasingly
backed himself into a corner
um we know the Ukrainian Army aren't
backing down President Putin has to go
back to the Russian people and present
to them a win has to um you know give
the impression that this is a war that
Russia is you know ultimately going to
emerge Victorious and so you know it's
unsurprising to see that he's you know
lashing out and becoming more violent in
the form of these civilian
um you know civilian attacks and I think
it just speaks to the fact that actually
this conflict is growing increasingly
convoluted and it's increasingly
difficult to see an easy way out
um that you know is relatively peaceful
at this point okay because of time I'm
just going to move on to our last story
and this is the crown the the new series
and the depiction of Prince Philip Noah
take us into this
yeah so the series has come under a bit
of fire uh by some uh royalists who say
that it is perhaps a bit insensitive to
be depicting uh Prince Philip's Affair
uh so quickly after
um her late Majesty Queen Elizabeth
passed away which Netflix is due to do
when the new series of the crown comes
out on November 9th
what are your thoughts on this Jasmine
are you a fan of the crown I mean
actually embarrassingly I've never
watched it not even one episode I mean I
do think that the timing is is slightly
awkward but you know to a certain extent
there's always public interest in the
Royals what they're wearing who's having
an affair with who and so I can
understand why Netflix is chosen to
capitalize on this moment of heightened
public interest in the worlds and
actually you know push forward to you
know push forward for this but I can on
the flip side appreciate that if you're
a royalist you do think actually it's a
bit insensitive this can hang on for a
couple of months it doesn't have to be
shown now